i'm not even going there but staying on
just laying
us so you believe there's some power in
her what do you think happens to her
no like what what are the greatest great
question i mean i don't
know what'll happen to her but i imagine
she'll get some type of deal
a closed door thing years from now when
people don't really care about the case
and she'll
serve some time in a very relaxed thing
or she'll be killed i mean again it's
like
if she was doing what she was doing
which is i believe the fact that she was
compromising powerful people
so that they could be blackmailed by uh
you know the intelligence uh services of
the us and israel
um probably i don't i don't see how she
wasn't doing that
someone's black someone's using the
photos and the tapes right
someone's using that against these
people someone wants to control these
people
well who and why that's the real
question and i think the real question
is you want to
you want to exert control over
congressmen and senators and
presidents because they have the power
to make decisions to affect the but the
cia just works for
a lot of very wealthy people that's what
the cia so how the cia
started right it was lawyers bankers
they're protecting
financial interest of multinational
corporations all over the world
overthrowing democratically elected
governments going in and doing
subterfuge campaigns encouraging terror
they were doing all kinds of crazy stuff
i don't see why that would change i
think that's who they still represent
and i think those people want
uh certain policies and certain people
pushed forward
and i think those people are controlled
and i think one of the ways to control
people is their sexual
problems and and that's the way they did
it
you